Transcriber: ayliz bayramoğlu
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Merhabalar.
Ben Profesör Doktor Özden Ağra, Yıldız
Teknik Üniversitesi Makine Mühendisliği
bölümünde öğretim üyesi
olarak çalışmaktayım.
Bugüne kadar farklı kişilerin hikâyelerini
dinleyip onlardan ders almak
hep benim için çok güzel
bir hatıra anı olmuştu.
Bugün de sıra bana geldi.
Kendi hikâyemi burada anlatmak istedim.
Bilmiyorum, ilham verecek mi sizlere
ama bazılarınıza bazı noktalarda
dokunacağını düşünüyorum.
TED Platformu, kişilerin hikâyelerini,
başarılarını anlattığı çok güzel
bir platform.
Bugün burada olmaktan ben
de gurur duyuyorum.
Teşekkür ediyorum.
Konuşma daveti geldiğinde ve konunun da
Reborn olduğu söylendiğinde ben daha
düşünemeden öğrencilerim dedi ki, mutlaka
sizin orada olmanız gerekir.
Umarım konuşmanın sonunda sizler
de aynı fikir içerisinde
olursunuz diye düşünüyorum.
Öncelikle kendime şunu sordum:
Yeniden doğmak ne demektir?
Nasıl anlatmam lazım?
“İnsan ne zaman yeniden doğar,
zorda kaldığı zaman,”
diye cevap geldi kendi kendime.
Peki her yeniden doğuş için bir zorluk mu
gerekiyor, yoksa bir zorluklar sonucunda
mı yeniden doğuş meydana geliyor?
Yok, tabii ki öyle değil.
Mühim olan sizin o noktaya gelmeniz ve
verdiğiniz karardan geri dönmeden
dümdüz ileriye doğru gitmeniz.
Yeniden doğuş!
Çok sevdiğim ve hayat boyunca bir felsefe
olarak kendimde hep tuttuğum bir hikâyeyi
sizle paylaşmak istiyorum.
70 yıl gibi hayatları olan kartallardan
bahsetmek istiyorum.
40′lı yaşlara geldikleri zaman
bir karar vermek zorunda oluyorlar.
Kartallar anlatılanlara göre 40′lı
yaşlarında pençeleri sertleşiyor
ve avını tutamıyorlar.
Kanatları ağırlaşıyor,
kartlaşıyor, uçamıyorlar.
Bu durumda kartallar için bir yol var.
5 ay süren yeniden doğuş hikâyesi.
Buna karar verenler,
bir dağın tepesinde, korunaklı bir bölgede
kendilerine bir yer yaptıklarında
önce sert bir yüzey bulup gagalarını,
duvara sürte sürte
parçalanmasını sağlıyor.
Düşen gaga,
bir müddet sonra yenilendiğinde
sertleşen pençelerini koparıyor.
Yenilenen pençeleri ile de ağırlaşan
kuş kanatlarını kopardıktan sonra
yeniden uçuyor.
İşte şimdi ben de burada
bugün Özden Ağra’nın
35 yaşından sonraki yeniden doğuş
hikâyesini size anlatacağım.
1964 aralık ayında doğdum.
Ama ne doğma, doğumum bile problemli.
Şu anda Mecidiyeköy’de bulunan
Torunlar Center yerinde
eskiden Ali Sami Yen Stadı vardı.
Babam da Türkiye-Bulgaristan
maçına gitmiş.
Annemin sancıları tutuyor.
Hastaneye giderken radyoda bir anons:
Ali Sami Yen Stadı çöktü,
çok fazla yaralı var.
Tabii o ruh haliyle ben dünyaya geliyorum.
Allah'tan ki babama bir şey olmuyor.
Benden on yedi ay sonra bir kız
kardeşim dünyaya geliyor.
Bizim çocukluğumuz ve genç kızlığımız
çok güzel bir şekilde geçiyor.
Liseyi Nişantaşı Kız Lisesi'nde okudum.
Lise sıralarında da sınıf başkanı,
disiplin kurulu başkanı olarak
okulda da tanınan aktif bir öğrenciydim.
Üniversite sıralarına geldiğim zaman ilk
önce ailemdeki erkek kuzenlerimin
benim için biçtikleri meslek
tipiyle karşılaştım.
Makine mühendisi olan erkek kuzenlerim
dediler ki sen bir kız olarak
kimya mühendisliği sana uygundur.
Tabii bu benim için çok uygun
bir şey olmadı.
Tercihlerini teslim edeceğim
sabahın akşamında
Yıldız Üniversitesi Makine
Mühendisliği bölümünü yazarak kazandım.
Kendi eğitim görmek istediğim
bölümü kendim seçmiştim.
Ama Kız Lisesi’nden sadece 5 kızın olduğu
yüz kişilik bir sınıfa gelmiştim.
Benim için çok büyük bir değişimdi,
ilk sene çok güzel geçti.
Derslerim çok iyiydi.
80′li seneler olduğu için Türkiye’nin
70′li senelerindeki okula gidemeyen
öğrencilere de af çıkmıştı ve aftan da
birçok öğrenci okula kayıt olmuşlardı.
Derslerim çok iyi olduğu için hocalarım
dedi ki, “Senden yaşça da büyük ama
gelenlere ders verebilir misin?”
Lise yıllarından beri ders anlatmayı
çok sevdiğim için tabii dedim.
3 sene boyunca çok sayıda af öğrencisine
ders vererek
hem de harçlığımı çıkartmıştım.
Her şey çok güzel gidiyordu.
Üniversiteyi bitirdim.
İstanbul Lisesi İşletme İktisadı
Enstitüsü’ne kaydoldum.
Aynı zamanda da okulumuzun yüksek lisans
bölümüne kaydımı yaptırdım.
Tam çok güzel,
artık her şey yoluna girmiş derken
birden bire babamı kaybettim.
Bu inanılmaz bir şeydi.
Çünkü babam benim idolümdü kahramanımdı.
Her genç kızın olduğu gibi.
Yirmi bir sene sonra ondan ayrılacağımı
hiç düşünmemiştim.
Masal gibiydi yani
bir varmış, bir yokmuş.
Hayat böyle işte.
Siz kendi hayallerinizin peşinden giderken
planlar yaparken o da size
farklı sürprizler hazırlıyor ve hayatınızı
darmaduman edebiliyor.
Nitekim bugün yaşadığım bir şeyi
de anlatmak istiyorum.
Burada olmak benim bir hayalimdi.
Fakat dün 40 senelik çok sevdiğim
can arkadaşımı kaybettim.
Bugün konuşmadan sonra da hızlıca
onu ebediyete uğurlamak
için ayrılacağım buradan.
Mecburduk hayata devam etmeye.
Ama ben babamın yokluğuna bir türlü
alışamadım, alışamadım
ve ani bir kararla evlendim.
Birkaç sene sonra eşimle görüş
farklılıklarımız meydana geldi
ve yollarımızı ayırmaya karar verdik.
Tabii kolay değil.
12 senelik bir evliliği birkaç cümleyle
burada özetlemek kolay değil.
Ama bir karar vermek zorundaydım.
Hayata yeniden tutunmak zorundaydım.
Karşınıza iki şey geliyor.
Ya hayat bitti, artık her şey boş
ya da her şey yeniden başlıyor.
Ben ikincisini seçtim.
Her şey yeniden başlıyor dedim.
Ama şunu da biliyordum.
12 senedir çalışma fırsatı bulamamış,
bekâr bir anne.
Çevrenin bakışları, önyargılar,
iş dünyasının size tutumu.
Bunlar benim için zor olacaktı.
Bunu biliyordum ama bunu çok rahat
göğüsleyebilirim derken tabii bana bu
konuda çekirdek ailem, annem, kardeşim,
oğlum, dostlarım, arkadaşlarımla
ben tekrar ayağa kalktım.
Bu çok zorlu bir süreçti.
Ama benim için bir dönüşümdü, benim
için yeniden bir doğuş olabilirdi.
Çünkü hayalini kurduğum üniversitede
öğretim üyeliği vardı ve bizim
zamanımızda 35 yaşını doldurduktan
sonra akademiye giremiyordunuz.
Benim altı ayım vardı.
Denemem lazım.
Hayalime mutlaka ulaşmam lazım.
ALES sınavına girdim.
Bir hakkım var.
Hatırlıyorum da sonuç geldiği
zaman uzun süre bakamadım.
Ama sonra baktığımda dedim ki evet,
istenen puanın üzerinde almıştım.
Bir adım yaklaştım ama bir
adım daha korkuyorum.
Neden çünkü doğum günüme kadar
eğer kadro ilanı çıkmazsa
hayallerim yine bitmişti.
Nitekim hayat orada bana güldü.
Kasım ayında açılan araştırma görevliliği
sınavıyla Makine Mühendisliği Bölümüne
kaydımı yaptırdım.
Evet, hayallerime ulaşmıştım.
Bir adım daha gelmiştim hayalime.
Burada bir karar daha vermem lazım.
Ben hayallerimin peşinden koşarken
birilerinin daha hayallerine veya
onlar için bir şeyler yapabilirsem
bu beni mutlu edecekti.
Bu konuda da hep Deniz Yıldızı
hikâyesinden ilham alırım.
Belki birileriniz biliyordur.
Okyanus kıyısında yürüyen birisi
yürürken karşıdan gelen böyle deniz
yıldızlarını atan birisini görür denize.
Biraz daha yaklaştığında
“Niye atıyorsunuz onu deniz yıldızlarını
denize,” dediğinde yaşamaları için der.
Bu kadar çok deniz yıldızını nasıl
atacaksınız, nasıl bunlara yetişeceksiniz,
dediğinde adam bir tane daha alır atar.
Bak bunun için çok şey değişti der.
Evet, eğer biz de birilerinin hayatına
biz olduğumuz için
olumlu dokunuşlar yapabilirsek
bu bizim için en büyük mutluluk olacak.
Evet, benim deniz yıldızlarım.
Ben de değerlerimizi kaybettiğimiz
bu günlerde
tek çıkış yolunun eğitim olduğunu
bildiğim için deniz yıldızlarımı
hayata hazırlarken onlara hep
şöyle motivasyon veriyorum.
Siz seçilen değil, seçen olmalısınız.
Siz tüketen değil, üreten olmalısınız
şeklinde motive etmeye çalışırım
deniz yıldızlarımı.
Şimdi tekrardan araştırma görevliliği
şeyime geleyim size.
Kendimden 10 yaş küçük arkadaşlarımla
sınavlara giriyordum.
Asistanlık yapıyordum.
Aynı zamanda da doktora tezini
hazırlamaya başlamıştım.
2000'li yıllarda üniversite sanayi
işbirliği yeni yeni başladığı için
sanayinin bir problemine çözüm bulma adına
biz şirketlerle görüşmeye başladık.
Burada da Türkiye'nin önde gelen
şirketlerinden birisinin yöneticisiyle
görüşürken bize şunu söyledi.
Yapacağımız test çok güzel.
Desteklenmeye değer.
Ancak okulunuzla bizim işbirliğimiz
olmadığı için destek olamayacağız size.
Yılmadık,
bana inanan hocalarımla
Biz o şirketle çok güzel bir tez yaptık.
Şimdi de aşağı yukarı 15 senedir gelen
güzel bir işbirliklerimiz var.
Test sırası kolay bir şey değildi.
Deneysel bir çalışma yapacaksınız.
Bir deney tesisatın hazırlanması lazım.
Bunun için de Çağlayan’da arkadaşımın
atölyesinde her cumartesi günü bir sene
çalışarak mükemmel
bir deney tesisatı yaptım
ve deneylerime başladığımda, okulun
laboratuvarına getirdiğimde
herkes gelip görüp
bir şeyler bakmak istiyor.
Fakat 9 kilo patlayıcı ve yanıcı
bir akışkanla çalışıyorum.
Tabii bu sefer hocalarım dedi ki,
“Aman bir şey olursa geri dönüşü olmayan,
telafisi olmayan şeyler olabilir.
Sen bunu bir odanın içerisine al.”
Laboratuvarın en sonunda bir odanın
içerisinde aylar günler çalışmaları tek
başıma 7-8 saat süren çalışmalar sonucunda
Aralık 2007′de doktoramı aldım.
Doktoramı aldığım zaman geçici kadrodan
asil kadroya geçtiğimde
omuzlarım biraz daha dikilmeye başladı.
Bizim zamanımızda doktorasını alan
arkadaşlarımıza hemen
yardımcı doçent kadrosu verilirdi.
Bu sefer dediler ki, yardımcı
doçent kadrosu yok.
Peki ne yapacağız,
istiyorsan doçentliğe çalış.
Öyle de kolay değil.
Onu istediğiniz kadar çalışmalarınız
tamam olsun,
istediğiniz kadar dosyanız iyi olsun.
Siz ders vermediğiniz için,
proje yaptırmadığınız için,
öğrenci yetiştirmediğiniz için,
inceleyen jüri tarafından geri
dönebilir dosyanız, red yiyebilirsiniz.
Kaldı ki bir de beni çok sevdiğini
söyleyen okuldaki kadın bir hocamın
jüriyi olumsuz etkileyip bana olumsuz
yaptırdığını,
olumsuz düşünce yazdırdığını gördüğümde
daha da üzüldüm.
Ama dosyam ilk geçti.
Sözlüye aldılar beni.
Zorlu bir süreçten sonra doçentlik aldım
ve ondan sonra da
çok özel bir günde benim için
8 Mart 2017′de profesörlüğümü aldım.
Artık dünyaya biraz daha omuzlarım
dik bakmaya başladım
çünkü devamlı olarak
kendime söylediğim şey
daha iyi, daha iyisini nasıl yapabilirim
şeklinde motive ediyordum.
Evet, bundan sonra dedim ki,
“Evet, ben hayallerime ulaştım,
ben hayallerime ulaştım.
Bundan sonra neler yapabilirim
deniz yıldızlarım için.”
Okula girdiğim ilk günden itibaren
öğrencilerimle ve özellikle
kulüp çalışması yapan
arkadaşlarıma desteklerim olmazsa olmazdı.
Hâlâ da elimden gelen her şeyi yaparım.
Bu durumda dedim ki kendime bazı
mottolar belirlemem lazım.
Nasıl onları hayata daha vizyoner
hazırlayabilirim diye düşündüğümde,
birinci olarak birinci sınıfta
test çocuklarına test çözerek gelen
ve meslek sahibi olmaya
çalışan arkadaşlarım için.
Ülkemizin önde gelen sanayi kuruluşlarının
iş adamlarını dersimizde misafir ederek
onların başarılarını, tecrübelerini,
başarısızlık olaylarını anlatmalarını
ve arkadaşlarımla,
öğrencilerimle bir araya getirerek
onlara vizyon vermeye çalıştım.
Bir ikinci şeyim de, yapmak istediğim de
yıldızlı mezunlarımla
öğrencilerimi bir araya getirmek.
Çünkü hepimiz bir olursak, beraber
olursak, ortak bir sinerji yaratırsak
daha güçlü bir network’ümüzle
öğrencilerimizi hayata
daha güçlü hazırlayabiliriz.
Ben de sadece derse girerek değil de
sosyal etkinliklerde de mezunlarımızı da
bir araya getirmeye özellikle
çok özen gösterdim.
300 öğrencim ile beraber makine
mühendisi aday öğrencilerinin
görmesini istediğim örneğin
bir tanesini Asfaltın Kralları
filmine götürmüştüm.
Böyle o kadar çok etkinliğimiz var ki
daha sonra onlarda geri dönüşler
onların ne kadar daha iyi
hazırladığımı gösteriyor.
Tabii en önemli bir konum daha var.
Burada da benim makina mühendisi
olamayacağımı söyleyenlere inat,
bu mesleği seçip de gelen kızlarıma
özellikle daha pozitif ayrımcılık yaparım.
Onlar için elimden gelen her şeyi yapıp
daha dik hayata atılmalarını
sağlamaya çalışıyorum
ve biz bugün kocaman bir aileyiz.
Ama duruyor muyuz?
Durmuyoruz.
Öğrencilerimle beraber çeşitli
platformlardaki yarışmalara girerek
dereceler alarak
biz gelişmeye devam ediyoruz.
Tabii burada buraya kadar
anlattıklarımdan bir şey çıkartıyorum.
Bizi biz yapan şeyler hayat
yolunda gerçekleşiyor.
Ne yapmak istiyorsanız mükemmel
bir hayatı boş verin.
Siz sizi heyecanlandıran yoldan yürüyün.
Sizi heyecanlandıran yol sizin ayak
izlerini çünkü oluşturacak
ve tabii konuşmamın burasında da
benim bugünlere gelmeme olanak
sağlayan ilham aldığım
kişilerden de bahsetmek istiyorum.
Tabii ki çok genç yaşta hayat arkadaşını
kaybedip bize hem anne hem baba olan,
her zaman pozitif duran çok
güçlü karakter annem.
Her ne kadar yanımda olmasını istesem de
o 32 sene önce Amerika'ya gidip iyi bir
eğitim ve iş hayatı olan kardeşim
ve tabii ki oğlum Emrecan.
Biz beraber büyüdük bu yolda Emrecan’la.
Zor bir süreçti.
Ama bugün dönüp baktığımda onun çevreye,
insanlığa, doğaya duyarlı bir genç
ve başarılı bir iş insanı
olduğunu görmek beni
önce anne sonra bir eğitimci
olarak çok duygulandırıyor.
Kız yeğenlerim Selin ve İpek de
bana her zaman destek oldular.
Tabii bu yolda sadece çekirdek ailem değil
beni devamlı olarak destekleyen dostlarım,
arkadaşlarım haricinde akademik
yolda bana her zaman destek olan
değerli hocalarımı da söylemeden
geçemeyeceğim.
Doğan Özgür hocam, Ahmet Rasim
Büyüktür’ü rahmetle anarken,
tez hocam İsmail Teke ama bir kadın olarak
beni her zaman cesaretlendiren,
benim her zaman yanımda olan Seyhan
Uygur Onbaşıoğlu’na minnettarım.
Ben ve onlar gibi gelecek nesillere
faydalı olmak için elimden gelen her şeyi
yapmaya devam ediyorum.
Hayallerim bitti mi?
Tabii ki bitmedi.
Daha yapacak çok şeyim var ama ben bu
yolda mutluyum ve bana bu yolda
beraber olmak isteyen öğrencilerime,
akademideki yol arkadaşlarıma
kapım her zaman açık olacak.
Son olarak konuşmamın sonuna geldiğimde,
arkadaşlarınızı iyi seçin.
Özellikle hayat arkadaşlarınızı iyi seçin.
Size engel olmayacak, sizin önünüze engel
çıkarmayacak, yanınızda olacak,
sizinle beraber büyüyecek,
sizinle güzel işlere imza atacak
arkadaşınızı seçin.
Hayat boyunca birçok pürüzler çıkacaktır
hayatınıza ama belki de onlar sizin
yeniden doğuşunuza neden olacaktır
ve ben deniz yıldızlarımla yeni hikâyeler
yazmaya devam edeceğim.
Umarım hikâyeme sizleri
de ortak edebilmişimdir.
Teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkış)